Xbox Series X logo revealed warzone has
some interesting ways to deal with
cheaters and did your Nintendo account
get hacked I'm Lucy and welcome to your
safe State for Wednesday April 22nd
national jelly bean day I got some jelly
beans like jelly beans first up
Microsoft has filed a new trademark
application for the series X console
including what appears to be its logo
admittedly trademark applications
sometimes don't pan out here's looking
at you Cod space warfare but given that
we know that's the consoles name this
one is more likely to be legit to be
honest I actually kind of like it it
looks different enough but it's still
super sleek what do you think
and speaking of Cod a new patch is
fixing some huge warzone exploits
players have found a way to use game
battles to create custom weapon
blueprints that could then be used in
any multiplayer mode and warzone that's
gone as is an exploit that made people
invincible after revives in specific
circumstances but most interesting is
that Infinity Ward is trying to clamp
down on cheaters by throwing them all
into a game with each other
respawn did this were titanfall and
honestly it's a great way to deal with
them throw them in the sin bin
incredible news so splatoon fans it's
getting a free trial at a brand-new
splatfest from April 29th to May 6th
you'll be able to play all the games
online modes for free if you're not
already subscribed to Nintendo switch
online then double good news because
Nintendo is giving out a free 7-day
trial alongside the demo they'll also be
a new splatfest its first in nearly a
year
ketchup vs Mayo running between May 22nd
and May 24th team ketchup obviously
fortnight is finally officially on the
Google Playstore feels while to actually
say it but you no longer have to go
through the convoluted process of
downloading the game from epics website
to play it on your Android device if
they can Google had a big old public
dispute over the 30% cut that Google
wanted to take from in-app purchases but
it looks like epic is back down because
Google hinders games that are
distributed through the Play Store in a
statement to polygon epic said that it
came to a basic realization Google puts
software downloadable outside of Google
Play at a disadvantage through technical
and business measures such as scary
repetitive security pop-ups for
downloaded and updated software
restrictive manufacturer and carrier
agreements and dealings Google public
relations categorizing third-party
software sources as malware and new
efforts such as Google Play protect to
outright block software obtained outside
the Google Play Store
oof well I guess from epics point of
view getting some of that revenue is
better than getting none of it at all
and finally a PSA setup two-factor
authentication on your Nintendo switch
if you haven't done so already a number
of people are reporting account breaches
we've got all the steps on site it's
very simple to do and honestly better to
be safe than sorry alright that's it for
today you can find me on Twitter I met
Lucy James games and for all the latest
gaming news stories keep it GameSpot
[Music]